hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be making
an in-game video on the vancouver
position recent videos i've made the
feedback has been
you definitely want to see more in-game
tactics videos that's exactly what we
are going to do
over the next two months planning to do
about two to three videos
per week until november first uh you may
have seen the news november 1st
just announced is going to be the
candidates tournament
being resumed so canada's tournament
earlier in this year was cut off halfway
exciting tournament but with all the
craziness going on in the world they did
postpone that
until november 1st so i plan on making a
lot of
in-game videos until then but it's all
based on feedback from
the audience so if you wouldn't mind you
do like this content feel free to hit
that like button lets me know that you
like this type of content
also feel free to let me know in the
comments if there's any type of in-game
you're looking uh for me to cover i
think rook
and pawn in games are very fun uh to
to go over and to learn from but if you
want to see pawn
in games uh queen versus rook type in
games uh minor psn games any of that
just let me know in the comments i'll
definitely take that into
consideration so in the vancouver
position uh
it's going to be set up similar to this
doesn't have to be exactly this
hopefully at the end this video you'll
have a better understanding of
conceptually how to play this not
necessarily just memorizing
moves although in the end game much of
it is understanding very specific moves
but one thing to keep in mind is you
want to have
this rook on one side of the board as
well as the king
near this eighth rank in your opponents
uh you can see here that they have a
rook and pawn and while they are up of
material
black can actually draw this game now i
know many of you
like to watch a video and say how can i
win but sometimes chess isn't always
about winning
it is about coming out with the best
outcome and in this case black down a
pond and material
and the white pawn about to promote here
to the eighth rank
black definitely should be playing for a
draw and they can do that
if they play correctly but definitely
needs to make sure that you have the
right setup so the first thing
is with the rook here on this side of
the board that it can freely attack this
king that we'll go over
and also the king near the eighth rank
you also want to make sure that the pawn
here
is has not reached the seventh rank yet
it's going to be very difficult for
black to draw that game we'll go over
both of those and why
that is the case and then we'll dive
into this position specifically
first we'll look at why white would win
if the pawn is already on the seventh
rank and that is let's say it's white's
move
now i've already done a video on a queen
versus rook in game so if white's
feeling
pretty confident in their skills they
could play rook here to g8 and after the
king takes
pawn two a8 and this is going to promote
to a queen here
and so white should win this game not an
easy end game by any means a white
definitely has
a better option much easier option and
that is just to play something like rook
to
c8 and it doesn't really matter how
black continues
they can't come to c6 and check the king
here but
if they want to play rook to f4 the
king's just going to come up to the pawn
there's no way to stop this
rook to f5 check king to b6
rook here to f6 check but then
eventually after rook 2 f7
just rook to c7 stopping that there's no
way for black to hold
on white should go on to easily win this
game
and now we'll look at even if the pawn
is on the sixth rank here
what happens if the king is not near
this
eighth rank well white can just play
rook here to
g8 and then let's say king two h4
and the reason h4 and not uh f4
white's not trying to continue to check
this king and so
uh black wants to potentially be able to
freely check
uh this king here and if the king is
here on f4 uh that would block some of
the squares that this rook could go to
but doesn't really matter too much
that's not in white's plans after the
king moves either way
then the pawn is going to push 4 to a7
and there's no way for black to stop
this
if black tries to just check the king
all day long
then eventually the king's going to come
up here to the 8th rank
and it's next to the pawn and there's
just nothing that black
can do here uh black's gonna have to
just take this pawn or
this pawn is gonna promote to a queen
here on eight
which brings us back to this original
position
and it's white's move now white has a
few options here
we've already looked at something like
g8 but that doesn't work because the
king as we mentioned
is protecting this so king to
gh just taking that material well
black's going to go on to to win this
game here so white's not going to do
that
so they're either going to push the pawn
forward to a7
because if they move the rook to
anywhere then this rook on
f6 is just going to take that pawn so
they're probably going to play
a7 or they're going to move their king
to b5 and try to get their king involved
into the action so let's look at both of
those make sure you understand
what white could do and then how black
should respond so a7
is going to get met by rook to a6
now this is crucial because in this
position
white can't really do much if this rook
moves anywhere it doesn't matter
we've already talked about if the rook
moves to g8 it's just going to fall to
the king that'd be a ridiculous move but
if it moves anywhere
rook to d8 well then the rook's just
going to take here on
a7 so let's say that the king starts to
get involved into the action with king 2
b5 attacking the rook
will the rook can just swing back to a1
now eventually the the king can start to
march down here to
this rook and start to attack it but
black has a easy response so let's say
king to b4
we could see check king 2 c3
black just comes back to a1 protecting
this a file this is the the critical
thing that black is trying to do here it
doesn't matter too much about the king
it's not a threat right now
as soon as it becomes a threat king to
b2
then black can play rook to a6 same as
before you can see
white's moved his king a bunch but it
hasn't really done anything
black is still stopping all of the
threats as soon as the rook moves
the pawn is going to be captured
so we've looked at the pawn coming to a7
and why that doesn't work for white so
let's take a look at the next option
that is the king getting involved so
king to
b5 now black really needs to
continue to check this king if it's in a
threatening position by threatening i
mean it's over here connected to
these pieces because it's adding a lot
of support
and so it needs to be put under attack
if it's not over here if it's in like
the center of the board
then black could just maintain control
of this sixth rank right here because
the rook can't really move too much
and if it does then the pawn just gets
captured and if the pawn ever pushes
forward then the rook can just swing
here to a6
so king to b5 and then rook to f5 check
king to c6 rook to f6 check and then
white has two options could either
retreat the king back here to b7 or b5
if really wanted to but
let's say b7 or it could play king to
d5 and just trying to get closer to the
rook so let's first look at
king to b7 now what's nice about this
position from black standpoint is the
king can never be
be get behind this rook or the pawn it's
very different than if the rook of the
pawn
if they were on the b file or the c file
because the king could just easily slip
behind them
and hide out and the king could not get
under
continuous checks from black but because
they're on the a file the king can't do
that so
black can pretty much just check the
king all day long
there's no way for white to stop this
now if we come back and say
after rook 2 f6 what if the king starts
to come closer to the rook now rook to
our king 2 d5 rook 2 f5 check
king 2 e6 rook 2 f6
check and then king 2 e5 now we can't
continue to check our opponent that's
fine because rook 2
f5 and rook to e6 are both just going to
get our rook captured but
the king here on the e file it's not
really a thread anymore we've kind of
neutralized it by bringing it towards
the center of the board and now we can
play rook 2
b6
now white still can't play pawn to a7
because we're just going to play rook to
a6 we already saw that that doesn't win
for white
white still can't play his rook anywhere
because we're just going to capture this
pawn here on
a6 so maybe the king comes to d5 and
says okay i definitely need to attack
but then just rook back to f6 now white
does have
an interesting move at this position
where they could play king 2 d4 and this
is where
you have to remember if the king is just
in the center hanging out
it's not really a threat then you could
still play just rook to b6
you're maintaining all the the threats
and defense that you had before
you don't want to fall into a trap which
this would be
of playing rook to f4 saying okay i
remember that i have to check well you
have to check
if your opponent's king is in a
threading position
king here on d4 is not a threat because
from here
they can play king to e5 attacking the
rook
and this is a losing position for black
and even if you look and say well yeah
you could just bring the rook back here
to f6
then if they're playing this in between
move here on d4 trying to trap you then
they
also probably know that they can play
the very nice move of rook to
g8 and black doesn't have a lot of good
options if they
take the rook here on g8 well then the
rook here on f6 is going to fall
if they play king 2 f7 well then we can
kind of force their hand because rook 2
f8
now they almost have to take and we take
their rook if they don't
they move their king anywhere then we're
just going to take the rook here on
f6 and if they decide something like
king 2
h7 okay well now the rook's just hanging
here on
f6 none of that's going to
go well so as we come back we can see
that there's just no reason to play rook
2
f 4 check instead black can just play
rook to
b6 now king 2
c5 no other option works we've already
looked at a7 many
times if the rook moves we just capture
the pawn here so
king two c5 rook back here to f6
what are they really going to do here
maybe since they've seen the pawn
pushing forward
doesn't work maybe they get the rook
involved rook two a seven uh check
but we can just bring a rook here to g6
behind the rook
uh that they don't have any more threats
so uh they also recognize that they need
to move the rook out of the way to move
the pawn
they can't move it along the seventh
ring because then they just lose the
pawn so rook back here to a8
we just bring our king back here to see
g7 it doesn't matter too much what are
they really going to do
and anytime that they just play a7 we
just play rook to a6
it's not going to win for them so that
is the vancouver position uh definitely
enjoy going over rook and pawn end games
it just happens
so frequently it's good to understand
how not only you can execute yourself
but also if you end up in a position
where you're you're down a pawn
or you're down some material and you're
figuring out like oh my gosh i wish i
could just draw this game i don't want
to lose
it's always good to understand in game
theory so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video again if you haven't already
hit that like button also not only if
you subscribe but hit that notification
bell because i will be creating a lot
more content
in the next two months i want to make
sure that you don't miss any of
the videos i'm making thank you guys so
much for watching
this one and i'll see you in the next
video in just a few days